suppose you're rolling a pair of dice
and you want to know the probability of
seeing various different sums each of
these are going to be weighted dice
there's a very pretty way that you can
visualize the computation you need to do
start by making a 6x6 grid of all the
possible outcomes then the probability
of seeing each one of the outcomes in
this grid looks like multiplying the
probability for the first die value
times the probability for the second die
value to be a little more visual you
could represent all of these values as a
three-dimensional plot now notice how
all of the pairs of dice values with a
given sum say a sum of six all happen to
sit along a certain diagonal of this
diagram likewise all of those pairs of
dice values that add up to seven sit on
another diagonal and so on so to think
about the distribution for all possible
sums what you can think about is
collapsing this full three-dimensional
plot along a diagonal Direction adding
up all the heights of These Bars along
each one of these
diagonals